your favorite candy oh my favorite candy
I never eat it but what is yours good
Sour Patch Kids man there's I can't eat
it too because it's so bad for you but
when I put a Sour Patch Kid in my mouth
oh talk about Caribbean
dude I just take a vacation man my [ __ ]
it's sour I love it dude but chocolate's
the best though I will say chocolate's
the best but dude when I take a [ __ ]
if I just put that on the tongue I guess
ah I go to the Caribbean man I hate sour
[ __ ] oh dude you dude you we wouldn't
have been friends as kids you eating
Sour Patch Kids
[Laughter]
then dress up as uh Rob and I'm like oh
oh well I'm not gonna be that kid dude
yeah yeah true and then singing
We Grew into being we met each other
when we were supposed to yeah I agree so
um favorite candy we'll have uh real
sense of teeth and I have cavities so I
can't eat candy but when I could it'd be
uh Butterfinger number one really Heath
Bar number two really oh I love good
Heath have you ever had a
Whatchamacallit yeah all right they're
all of them uh I like I like 100 grams I
like 100 Grand okay so we like all the
opposite ones oh do you like Good and
Plenty no no I love oh what these are
good friends I mean you guys like each
other's opposite you could trade
afterwards oh Ivory yeah because when
you take a pillowcase right and they put
all the candy pillow you're saying I'm
from Denver so we that's how we say it
though yeah
when you go to the Caribbean we go to
the pillow with a Caribbean but no we'd
fill up the entire Pelicans of the candy
and then me and my brother dump it out
and exchange he likes licorice I like
the chocolate wow it's a good combo that
is a good combo